justin trudeau says we are not
intimidated trudeau won't meet convoy
that continues to gridlock ottawa
before i read this
i want to give a trigger warning to all
the people who are uh who despise the
mainstream media because this one my
friends this one is a doozy and i'm not
literally giving you a trigger warning
i'm just building suspense because check
this out
they write for the toronto sun prime
minister justin trudeau says he will
neither meet with nor be intimidated by
the convoy of canadians he says spent
the last few days harassing local
businesses waving nazi flags and
stealing food from the homeless what wow
what are they what is
all of the smears i have seen of
protests in my day
that
is impressive and i was at occupy wall
street and boy did the media go after
them yeah but this is this is a bunch of
truckers yeah this is the lifeblood of
of any nation delivering goods angry
with vaccine mandates and protesting it
and that is the characterization used in
the media bravo bro i'm impressed also
can i ask a question these truckers are
stealing food from the homeless what
about the people who decided that we
needed to print trillions and trillions
of dollars and then inflated our
currency so that lower income people
have less of an ability to buy food are
they stealing food from the homeless
they're stealing from all of us
absolutely what about those people on
top of that decided we need to impose a
vaccine mandate on the truckers who
literally bring us our food oh yeah i
saw i saw a good post and it said it was
like a lefty thing and it said stop
saying labor shortage and start saying
living wage shortage and i responded
stop saying living wage shortage and say
inflation right
right yeah yeah the thing that strikes
me about this it's classic attack the
messenger right so they're going after
the truckers they're making these
ridiculous claims about the truckers
because they don't want to deal with the
substance of the issue and the other
thing i don't understand is he says he's
not going to be intimidated but
didn't justin trudeau like retreat or
leave he's hiding yeah he's literally
hiding i think he is intimidated by the
truckers isn't he i'm not scared of you
guys
i'm not scared at all right he's like
turning around he's like i will not be
intimidated breaking news justin trudeau
has fled ottawa to an undisclosed
location exactly so uh let me let me
read this is amazing speaking to
canadians from isolation after testing
positive recovery oh that's
he said freedom of expression assembly
and association are cornerstones of
democracy but nazi symbolism racist
imagery and desecration of war memorials
are not it is an insult to memory and
truth hate can never be the answer now
i'm going to tell you this when blm came
to ottawa he came out and he took a knee
with all of them right he marched with
them he protested with them
and i'll also say i i certainly think
anybody involved in that protest should
completely agree yeah nazi symbols
racism and all that stuff absolutely not
acceptable we agree thanks justin are
you still scared are you still going to
run away or are you going to come and
meet with the people on the substance
the answer is no well like during the
blm protest did he mention that burning
down
people's businesses and destroying their
ability to make a living is horrible and
bad and that he can't set with the
protest on that basis of course not and
then when we're looking at this he's
saying having nazi flags and desecrating
memorials are not something that i'm
willing to contend with okay then how
about we have a conversation about what
they're actually doing okay because if
any of them are even doing that it's a
tiny tiny fringe minority so why doesn't
he talk about the fact that there are
working-class people banding together to
protect their rights as workers
you know this is really interesting
because when i was reading about this
protest it sounds so much like occupy
wall street it sounds like how they went
after occupy and then my response was
hey you know radical left the radical f
did co-opt occupy wall street and turn
it into something else it was a populist
uprising there were libertarians there
were conservatives they were left they
were liberals and they were upset over
the banker bailouts within a couple
weeks though the radical left completely
co-opted the message and the money and
booted out anyone who opposed them so
you know people who wear this trucker
protest should make sure no ideologue
should be able to take that message yeah
here's the thing i don't get though i
mean it used to be you look back in the
60s you know reagan was governor of
california the anti-war protesters he
didn't agree with them but he'd meet
with them there used to be this
tradition you know if you're a political
leader and somebody's protesting and you
don't agree with them you try to at
least meet i mean justin trudeau is not
even prepared to meet with these guys
that's what's so shocking to me i mean
they've got thousands of people doing
this you've got support for it and
justin trudeau is like no i'm going to
pretend like you don't even exist yeah
exactly well whenever working-class
people try to band together to have
their voice heard it's insinuated that
there's something wrong with them as a
group of people for reasons that have
nothing to do with the actual cause
they're arguing for so tim mentioned
occupy wall street and how that was less
partisan when it began interestingly
enough the tea party which was generally
to the right was actually started on
msnbc it was a left-wing pundit who said
we need a modern day tea party because
it is taxation without representation to
spend money that future generations will
have to pay off right but then of course
the tea party was instantly maligned as
a racist movement right and there were
politicians who claimed i can't remember
who maybe you guys do but that they
called them the n-word and other racial
slurs oh yeah uh and all of the footage
from the event showed that that did not
happen right right that's the go-to
thing now unfortunately and
look i think we all agree that there are
racists out there and they say racist
things and do racist things but every
single time now there's an event or in a
protest this becomes kind of the
shorthand prescription for what's wrong
with the people or that they're all
doing it and i i just don't buy it i
mean i'm sure that maybe there are a
couple of uh knuckleheads that are doing
stupid and hateful things among the
group but the vast majority and we're
just they're canadian truckers i mean
how bad can they be right they're
ordinary working class people and this
becomes kind of a go-to explanation for
everything it's really disappointing
because when you do actually have cases
of racism that occur people don't
believe it anymore yeah i also just want
to mention it was john lewis who claimed
that he was called racial slurs by the
tea party there was zero evidence for it
and in fact there was evidence that
we're here we hear the same thing with
chuck schumer and the january 6
protesters he said they were yelling
things about jews and everyone like just
like oh come on those the writers did a
lot of things but that one is just so
over the top hard to believe yeah show
me the footage this is funny check this
out they say
uh he said people were waving hateful
flags including swastikas and the
confederate flag
all right well i did see a photo of
someone with a nazi flag and i'm
genuinely confused by it but like i
guess you know look there are going to
be people and they're going to do dumb
stuff or have believed bad things the
confederate flag is the one that's
really weird to me y'all are in canada i
know what you're doing
so this guy's in saskatchewan right
right
even if someone there was legitimately
like i'm gonna wave this flag i'd be
like why right well the other thing too
is like these protests happen it
happened on occupy wall street these
truckers show up you know who's to say
the guy with a nazi flag is a trucker it
may have just been some nazi who was
around he was like i'm going to go in
the crowd and i'm going to wave my flag
around that's the thing too i was at a
protest in boston and i was anti-fun one
side the left and the right on the other
side and i was talking to some guy from
the dsa the democratic socialist of
america and uh i asked him what you know
what they were doing with what their
plan was and he was like we just want
you know health care for people and
better policing and i was like what
about you know what would you say to the
critics who would say that you guys are
just communists and that this is a front
and once you get power he was like
that's not true we don't endorse that
stuff
and then i asked him what he thought
about the right
and he was like look you got a bunch of
far-right extremists and racists i mean
look they're waving confederate flags
over there and i was like well that's
one guy with a confederate flag he's
like yeah well they're all standing
around him aren't they and i was like
well you guys are waving communist flags
he's like no we aren't and i turned
around like 20 feet away i'm like
there's a gigantic soviet union flag and
they're waving it and he went
well that's not ours
and i was like right right well the
guy's over there it's got one guy with a
confederate flag i mean right you don't
want to throw everybody lump i
understand there's you know different
groups of people here and you know i
don't know if they understand
what they're saying when they lump
everyone in
but it's it's the same old smear and
this one i gotta admit it's just
outright impressive it's just like the
degree to which the media and the
politicians are are desperate to go
these canadian men were waving
confederate flags like well are you it's
you know what it is it's they're
obsessed with american media right so
this is american
you know left sentiment seeping into
canada because i don't i'm look
canadians that are listening explain to
me why someone would wave the
confederate flag i don't i don't get it
the north will rise again
they're north of the north exactly the
north will rise again a yeah
exactly no it's so bizarre also i'm
still uh i'm still getting a kick out of
stealing food from homeless people
that's hysterical who decided like who
printed that is there a story yeah yeah
there's a story that uh some of the
people at the protest went to a homeless
shelter and demanded they give food to
the truckers and the homeless shelter
agreed to to de-escalate things
and then i you know you know i'm willing
to bet i'm willing to bet that it was
like some people walked to the homeless
shelter and said hey would you guys be
willing to give food to the truckers and
they went uh yeah sure thank you and
they're like oh they stole our food they
called the press help us please
something so like it's it's it's it's
mainstream press
i agree with you that it's probably
blown out of proportion but you do have
to be careful with large groups of
people um moving across countries like
that like i think about the um the
crusaders in the crusades man because it
would be all benevolent yay we're
fighting for god we're christian but
they're still human and they need food
so they just pillage on the way they mur
they just take people's food they just
kill they they shack up in people's
houses they and then so it can get
pretty bad but this is a different story
this is i like trucks it should be
condemned right right no matter what be
like hey look if that really happened of
course no one's okay with it there's a
story about a guy like apparently
someone threw you know feces at
someone's house because they had a pride
flag and i'm like well that sounds
really absurd to me is it a monkey but i
don't
know
what humanity does that i it sounds
really absurd but you know what i don't
care condemn it out right right nobody's
okay with that right and if
anybody involved in the in the trucker
protest should be like we're so sorry
someone would do it you guys they should
just outright feel like no one here
agrees with that we're sorry it happened
and with the tens of millions of dollars
raised if it were me that i do i'd say
we're going to clean that up for you
right we're going to cover that
because we want to make sure
you know in fact i would even allocate
money to general street cleaning i'd say
we're going to bring a lot of people you
know we got a lot of trucks coming
through we want to make sure that we can
leave the place where you live clean and
tidy up in fact there was what was that
protest where everyone cleaned up
afterwards recently
now i can't remember what it was we were
talking about it a few months ago like a
bunch of right-wing people came and they
protested they know what you're talking
about they all cleaned up the garbage
though yeah yeah yeah and when you when
you look at these left-wing rallies at
the women's march it's just totally
trashed right disgusting just
obliterated yeah yeah well here we are
so where does this end tim i mean you
know you've got these guys protesting
where does this end people are still we
have some super chats you know we save
them for the end but people are
mentioning that the convoy is not even
in the city yet oh really like it's been
it was 50 miles long yeah and so you
have 50 000 truckers so what we're
seeing is just the tip just the tip
entering yeah well i just want to say
i'm so proud of canada and canadians
here
my whole life i had this perception that
they were much more complacent and i
think that's the image of them that sold
to us especially because their
government is so much more restrictive
than ours but not long ago i started to
actually speak to people from canada and
i found that many of them are really
quite
convicted and and based and actually
understand what's going on and want to
resist uh tyranny and so i love that
they're sending this message to the
world
amen i don't know for sure if the
canadian if most canadians would be like
yo let's let's join the americans
instead of the british like if they had
to pick but i imagine they'd be like
yeah all right yeah what do you mean you
mean during the revolutionary no like
today if you got a side with democratic
freedom democratic republicanism or if
you've got to side with the monarchy you
side with democratic republicanism yeah
yeah uh uh quebec was the 14th the 14th
colony though you know they said no
they're like we will not declare
independence yeah it's an interesting
point you may because i was just reading
a book on uh the american revolution war
for independence and you know i always
kind of thought like everybody was on
board with kicking the british out and
the best estimate was like one-third of
them yeah wanted independence one-third
of them were loyal and the other third
were kind of in between and you kind of
wonder is that the way it always is you
know these big changes that you have
what's what's going on in canada right
now is it kind of the rule of thirds
right that that it's not an overwhelming
majority of people and you got to
persuade that other third so the things
you were talking about about cleaning up
the streets about condemning things
that's a way to win that other third and
get the majority
but i kind of feel like we're almost to
the point where there is no other third
you know we looked at a lot of polling
we've looked at a lot of polling over
the past several months the independent
base is is melting yeah as people keep
switching so there's people switching
from at least in the us right democrat
to republican
independents are being pulled left and
right with the biggest group of
independents going republican the
republican party is starting to balance
out and gain on the on the democratic
party but there's almost no middle
anymore if you're if you're a centrist i
mean like i feel like this show we do is
a balance of opinion it's called right
wing by the left right and it's it's the
most insane thing because i mean i i
watch some conservative shows and i'm
like i can certainly see the difference
between the show we do in the show they
do and so can our viewers but if you're
on the left it's all right-wing right so
when you get to that point it's almost
like do you really win that third or i
mean i guess so obviously we're trying
to we're trying to convince those people
to join freedom
and i think it's working because even
democrat voters are switching over to
republican not that republican is the
right answer mind you it's just like
people feel like it's their only
alternative right but things are
hyper-polarizing right but there are
there are a group of people who are kind
of apolitical right i mean they have
cultural opinions they but
a political and i agree with you it's a
diminishing group to what it used to be
um but i just want to believe and hope
that there is a persuadable group in the
country and that that you can and that's
why you need to do these things and
demonstrate you know how important uh
your views and values are and do things
like you were saying clean up the
streets and i think every everyone is
persuadable to a certain degree and i
think it's not about a middle ground a
one-third i think we're actually looking
at democrat voter base we're looking at
default liberal types i think that's
what andrew breitbart called them right
default liberals so they're they vote
democrat they align the democratic party
they say that they're democrats and now
they're watching what's going on and
they're rolling their eyes and saying yo
i'm out yeah many of them are voting for
republican many i think pew referred to
them as the stressed sideline yeah but i
don't think you know uh
it's large enough at this point i think
what's actually happening is
shows like this shows like joe rogan
and other you know other shows even
conservative ones and even some left
ones like jimmy dore are eroding at the
establishment narrative and it's
resulting in people just saying i'm done
with that group of people the celebrity
message i mean look at that story waving
nazi flags and hate symbols like
seriously right there was a tweet from
kurt schlichter is really funny i can't
remember exactly what he said but he was
like the left is really mad when that
the workers of the world are uniting
it's like it's kind of funny how that's
working out right and these are truckers
these are uh like you know typically
young younger to middle-aged guys who
are just driving on the road and you
know people of all different backgrounds
honestly who drive trucks but uh not the
kind of people you expect to be marching
around throwing bricks through windows
right right and here we are with the
smears and the manipulation and no i
mean yeah well these are people with a
sense of responsibility they have jobs
that's the entire reason that they're
protesting it's for their rights as
workers these are not irresponsible
teenagers who are going out trying to
destroy things like we saw for an entire
summer that was never condemned by any
of the people who are condemning all of
these truckers for something that a
fringe minority within their group is
doing and who quite frankly we don't
even know is a fringe minority within
their group they could just these could
just be randos showing up yeah yeah yeah
so you asked like where does this all go
you know what's fascinating that this
story is happening in canada
and uh you know i was talking with you
know people just before the show and i
think that's my brother who said it's
like a global civil war almost because
it's not just the united states
that's experiencing this cultural rift
it's it's europe canada the united
states australia australia
and to a certain extent australia and
new zealand but australia man
things are bad there what is it that the
british empire's crumbling is that
basically finally yeah maybe like 600
years or something
it's the culture that was born out of uh
mostly i guess british colonization
due to physics they figured out physics
first isaac newton so then they had
long-range cannon fire from boats and
they dominated the city
and uh and steam gatling guns i was
reading about allowed them to just
dominate but uh it's interesting it's
it's not just the former british
colonies and and you know kind the
commonwealth there's parts of europe too
but it really does feel like people say
western civilization and all that stuff
and i'm like it is very much like canada
the us australia new zealand uh britain
the five eyes spy club whatever you want
to call it certain parts of europe but
you look at some of these european
countries and they're like either
getting rid of their vaccine their
covent mandates completely right and
just go back to normal and then you look
at the united states you look at canada
you have to you look at the uk and this
the same culture war thing is happening
across the board
so why why is that i don't know but
when i talk about you know the potential
for civil war and stuff like that i do
find it fascinating that now the
establishment left is completely on
board with the narrative you know you've
got this one guy put out a book recently
the next civil war you've got msnbc
talking about the new york times the
wall street journal the atlantic they're
all now saying like where are we headed
and then if you actually you when we
look at what's going on with the
truckers we look at how trudeau responds
when they start claiming that
working-class people and trucks are like
evil white supremacist nazis and all
that stuff i'm like
there there is no convincing this other
side you either concede to them give
them concession or you assert yourself
now and recognize the groups are two
completely separate groups that will not
ever work together there's no convincing
them because klaus schwab and i don't
want to put it all on you klaus there's
probably other people involved they
don't want to
not think this it's inten they're
intentionally choosing to believe that
there's some sort of rift so it's like
you can't convince someone that is going
to
choose to believe it
does that make sense yeah yeah
i see i see luke's in the comments
trying to
help me look at him no we don't read his
comments now he left us yeah he did so
we'll just ignore luke's comments no no
luke said it was uh it's called the
great reset it's part of the great yeah
maybe but but uh thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you